Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to SCP Containment Breach
Now we just got murdered by Billy
Which is always fun
I'm always looking forward to the moments when Billy can murder us dead
But hopefully we can get back there and we can go where we need to go because
in there is the only way
I think
The only way to get to the heavy containment breach zone
Or the heavy containment area
But it just seems like Billy
*screw you billy*
decides to be a giant sack of shit all the time
So he generally is just an asshole
and we got to get by him
So
I imagine considering he's been there the past few times
*static noises*
He's gonna be there again
Which just means we got to deal with him
and I think what I got to do--
If I'm thinking about my math right, and I don't know if I am
But if I am thinking about my math right
Then I think...
I think thunky
erghh
I think that I need to go down,
deactivate the omega warheads
Because
To be honest
the only thing
Oh no... not there
Not there
NOO no no no
Ah oh olalala ting tang wala bala bing bang
There you are Billy.
Where you at Billy Billy?
Where you at Billy Boo?
I know you don't want me to go down there!
But I think, if I remember correctly
from the previous version of this game,
The only thing,
That was...
That the uhhh computer wanted from you
was to turn that off.
Because it knew that it could not move!
Therefore
it doesn't wanna DIE when everything BLOWS UP.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go deactivate them,
Because I don't know if I'm gonna be able to turn off remote door control
because I don't know where that was.
It may in fact be, oh and also that is the nuke right there, that's the...that's the five megatons of DEATH staring at us in the face.
So I need to do that, and that's gonna be super fun and awesome.
But I'm going to turn these off because I'm thinking
I'm just barely thinking with my big brain- that just maybe
He wants me to turn those off and he'll be willing to let me in and talk to me after that
Which means that he will disengage the locks to the heavy containment zone and therefore we'd be able to progress
But until that happens, everything's at a standstill,
and uh,
regrettably, if this doesn't work, I might have to go back in to the original light containment areas--
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?
I SAW THAT
OHH I SAW THAT
HEYYYY HIIII
H-OKAY
Well that's a little more unc--comfortable than I needed it to be
Ohhhhh alright, you stay right the frick frack there, you Billy Bitch
Alright
So behind me there should be a containment door
and if I close it, now I'm not gonna get bothered
by Billy, because Billy cannot open those doors
Billy does not have a key card
I mean I was reading up on SCP uh Wiki entries the other day
and there's some new ones that are really really really cool
Like legitimately cool
AWW COME ON, MAN
Oh hi...
What the fuck was that?
Oh, I thought that opened
Oookay
You're not going to get me a second time
Ahhh nah
ALRIGHT I GET IT, I get it...you don't want to be BOTHERED!
Oh fuck...
He's right outside the door...
Hi
Oh hi?
OH HI.
There you are
Alright, I'll just be on my way
Don't mind me... I--
Oh god--oh god--OH GOD--OH GOD!
Fucking hell...
Okay, so I gotta find a remote door control access
Which means I gotta go back
I don't know how far I gotta go back
But all I know is that I gotta go back!
Ahh-ohh, alrighty then!
Alright
I should be good after this
I should be okay
But then again, I've said that before and it didn't work out so well for me.
So I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna look at my map.
I think.... I need to go back the the light containment areas
because what I remember, and if you guys remember this, too,
ohhh shit
Huh...
You feel something NEAR YOU!
OHHHH!
HEY, HEY
WHERE THE FUCK DID YOU COME FROM?
WHY DIDN'T YOU GET ZIPPY-ZAPPED?
You little bitch.
Oh god...
ohh...
Alright it's fine.
Everything's fine.
You still down there?
Do I even want to check?
uhhh...
Okay, ALRIGHT THEN
Just gonna skedaddle because something's behind me!
Everything is goddamn killing me in this place--
Okay, so I need to get back
Just a little bit farther
And then I'm gonna need to make my way to the light containment area which I know there's probably a juncture...
Oh... what is this?
What is this again?
Oh this is the area where he came from.
Oh that's where I dropped all my shit.
Okay, alrighty then
And I definitely can't go through here because it's been locked down
Yeah, it's been locked down
So there's no point in all that.
So there is a way to go over here
And I'm gonna take off my gas mask because I can't see anything
HUGHAYY
This game, okay.
Alright, so, I think if we go south here
this should take us to where we need to go
And then, I believe- ohhh... fuck, I forgot about this
Where does this lead?
Hang on, lemme double check over here
where does this lead?
Okay, what is this again?
'Cus I wanna be THOROUGH about this
And, I don't wanna be
blockin' off my paths anywhere.
Ohhh, yeaah.
Ohhh, yeah!
OHHH!
I forgot about you!
And I forgot about the thing I needed th-the suit for...
Ohh, yeah.
Oh...
Oh, no...
Oh n...
Where...
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?!
H-ookay, alrighty, then...
Okay, I guess, I'm, going, to, uhh....
Turn on the gas valve-
Speaker: Fine, good luck getting out all on your own...
...HUH?
WHAT?
Who said that?!
Okay, I'm gonna...
Open the door, I- I guess...
SCP-035: Unfortunately, I never had any intentions of taking you with me.
SCP-035: So, this is where we part ways.
SCP-035: But, for the sake of my freedom,
SCP-035: I have reason to believe the SCP-079 has
SCP-035: taken control of the facility's systems
SCP-035: including the door system.
SCP-035: Your best bet is to appeal to it somehow.
SCP-035: Hopefully, you can come to a compromise.
SCP-035: However, it does not control the warheads.
SCP-035: Which you should disable remotely
SCP-035: in the event something goes wrong.
O-okay....
Alrighty, then...
Oh!
I...
Okay...
Am I stuck here now!?
I vaguely remember something about this working and it di...
I don't think it went like this...
Ahh, I can't do anything.
Hello?
Hello...?
Oooo.....
Hi...?
ok...
Alrighty, then...
Damnit...
Damnit!
I think I got bugged in here.
I gotta- I think I gotta load my save and come back *slight chuckle*
Okay!
I'm back, I just crossed the chasm
that's from where I just came.
So... this should be, um...
Yeah- uhh- I didn't do that...
Did I do that?
I didn't mean to do that...
But at least we know that Radical Larry is
not gonna be able to bother us anymore.
Hi, ducky! :)
How you doin'? :)
Ya' still bein a son-of-a-bitch?
Hahaha, I bet ya' are, ya' sack of shit...
Alright.
So, if I gooo... I belieeve... it's down here...
But I don't know if it's going to be open for me...
Yes, it is!
'Cus this is where Larry first popped in.
Or not first popped in
but, this is where he bothered us, anyway.
Alright, but nothin' is gonna bother us, though, now.
'Cus we are free-
*Loud alarm sound from opening the door*
Fucking hell!
Jesus!
There is no n-
*More rapid alarm sounds, followed by the door closing*
Alrighty, then!
Ohh, yeah, the Larry goop
I forgot about that.
Oh!
And, I forgot about this elevator
Where does this one go...?
And do I wanna go in it?
Kind want to save, first
was there a place to save around here?
Oh, I know Billy's gonna be around every corner, but-
I'm just hopin'.
One can hope and dream.
Ugh
Hello?
Ahh, good.
A defunct containment area.
Oh..
In here, mayb-
*Deep frightened inhale*
Hi!
HOW THE FUCK DID YOU GET THERE?!
Uhh...
*A mixture of laughing and frightened breathing*
I need to go through there, thank you very much!
Could you- huhuhuhu
Just, ya' know...
Let me go, Mr. Poop Butt Billy Boo~?
'Cus I need to go in heere...
Excuse me, please, do not bother me, I can save here.
UggGHH
So, that's where the Khmer script skull is.
Which is what I definitely do not need.
Hi, okay!
Hello, buddy!
Is that far enough?
Oh!
I think that's my blood.
Ugh...
Why do you have a bloody ear?
Ugh, I don't wanna know who you been' killing.
Alrighty, then.
*inhales*
Alright, okay, it's fine, it's fine.
So what is what's over here?
Nothing!
Okay.
So, I'm gonna use this to get away from him just a bit.
Just, because I don't wanna be bothered.
alright
Ska-doodley doo!
Ska-dood-a-loo
dood-a-lee-doo!
Okay.
So, I'm gonna go down here.
Just because I got a little side-tracked and I...
Ah, good. "The elevator appears to be broken."
"GONZALLES JIM"
Man, fuck you Jim.
You're no good to anybody.
Especially me.
Oh.
Ha.
Those are some reassuring steeps-steps.
Okay.
And there's another elevator here.
I don't know.
Nope.
Yeah, they all appear to be broken.
Maybe I should use the blood as the indictor...
...that maybe these elevators aren't for me.
Oh.
Up here.
That's right.
Was this the area?
Is it... oooh.
The fuck was that?
And what's in here?
"The door appears to be locked."
fucking...
What do you doing?
*Loud static noise*
Oh! Hi!
Okay.
I have no...I...I...
I don't...I don't even know.
*Noise that unexplained*
I don't even know.
Okay, so this isn't the place where the...
This isn't where the door control is but it looks a lot like it.
It's definitely not it.
Jesums.
Jesumsimsumsam.
Alright.
It's fine.
This is not where I'm supposed to be.
I though it was.
But it's not.
So I just gonna keep going til I find what I need.
Ah.
There's gonna be a place to turn off remote door control access.
I know that exists because it existed in the last one.
Oh.
Hi.
Is there something in there that I might need?
But I don't think I can get in there.
Can I?
Nah.
There's no way.
No way at all.
It's just a security checkpoint.
It's fine.
He didn't do his job very well. He let everyone through but...
Okay, that's locked and I don't need to be there.
So what I need to do is I need to keep moving...
...this way...?
Ohhhhh.
Ahhh.
Is this still activated?
Is that gonna zippy-zap me into next century?
Probably.
Let me go save before I go charging through there.
Cuz I can't remember if something actually died on that one or if it was just a fluke.
No......
How did you get up there?
Okay.
Alright, you stay up there.
You stay!
I don't even know how you found me.
I'm gonna test this thing out.
Yep, I'm fine.
Surprisingly, I am fine
Oh, another set of these maybe?
How 'bout this?
Okay, where is the... Oh.
Well, I don't know what these are.
Wait.
Hang on, let me take these off.
Oh.
Alright then.
Ah.
Is that the ring?
Oh.
I need that.
I... I need that.
Because the ring...
"SCP-714 is to be stored..." Blah, blah, blah.
"Seemingly nothing more than a jade ring..."
It has scheduled effects... ah... within moments of putting it on.
Wearers feel worn out, but...
This is important because it has a mental "shield".
It's very very good for you to resist...
Like the quote-unquote memetic effects.
Sort of same "meme" effects.
And then...
It's supposed to nullify the effect of various chemicals in the body.
Fully poisonous or toxic substances are generally not hindered.
And so what it means is...
I think...
This ring...
is gonna allow me to survive an encounter...
with the Plague Doctor.
And I'm not a hundred percent sure about that.
But I think...
That's what it's supposed to do.
Cuz if I put it on...
It doesn't do much for me now but it does reduce my ability to run, like greatly.
But if I take it off...
I'll eventually recover.
So let me see what's in here.
I don't remember.
I don't remember what that is.
I'm hesitant to just pick things up
You know what I mean?
So I'm gonna lock that one up just in a second.
Cuz the things that I don't know what they are.
They could very well kill me, very easily.
Hello?
Ahh.
Okay.
I'm going to drop a cup.
I'm gonna pick up this key.
I forget what this does.
It's either a key that unlocks anything or a key that unlocks a very specific door that takes me to, like a...
A dimension I don't wanna go to.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure that's the encyclopedia of common diseases.
And I'm not supposed to open that.
I'm pretty sure that's what that is.
Oh no.
What's through here?
Hang on.
Okay.
I need to find...
I need to find a computer terminal to save because I just got some goodies.
And I don't wanna lose em.
I know there's a Billy over here...
who wants to mess up my day.
Alright.
I'm gonna find one.
Okay.
BRB.
Okay. So I just saved.
And if I recall either this is the book where you write a story in there and it becomes true...
or it's the book where when you read the diseases it kills you.
I can't remember which, so let's find out.
I don't I need this anymore.
Alright.
Ah.
"Common Cold"
"also known as naso... is a virus... no cure..."
Yep, it's the one where you get every disease that you read.
Can I read this again?
Cancer of... Oh, "Cancer of the Lungs"?
Well, that's not good.
What's up next? Big boy.
"Appendicitis"
Oh no.
But I don't have an appendix
Well, that's gonna kill me eventually.
"Cardiac..." Oh no...
Uh oh.
Read another. Quick.
"Appendicitis"
Oh no.
Oh. Well, there I go. I'm dead.
So that's the bad one.
That is the no good one.
I don't know why they just keep that on a pedestal with no information about it.
Oh boy.
Ohh, "Memory access violation."
Okay. Well, that didn't work out too well, but that is all the time I got for this episode.
So I'm gonna find the remote door control and I'm going to figure out a way beyond that.
Because I know... I know for a fact there's a remote door control around here somewhere.
And I know for a fact that I haven't explored absolutely everywhere.
I still got 049...
crawling up my butt, but now I got...
this blue key.
And, I wonder where it goes to.
I'm not entirely sure. I can't remember if that's the key that sends me into a portal dimension or not.
Things get a little hazy after a few years.
But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know how I'm doing in the comments below.
And as always...
I'll see you... in the next video.
BYE BYE......
or not *music*